[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم سلمى الجمل
وفي
العناوين شهداء وجرحى فلسطينيون في اقتحام
قوات الاحتلال مخيم جنين في الضفه الغربيه
الجيش الاسرائيلي يقول انه اعتقل مطلوبين
وفصائل فلسطينيه تؤكد تصديها للهجوم وتقول
ان جرائم الاحتلال لن تمر دون
رد في كلماتهم في الامم المتحده بايدن
يحمل روسيا مسؤوليه الحرب في اوكرانيا
اردوغان يؤكد العمل على وضع حد للحرب
وامير دوله قطر يقول انه لا يجوز بقاء
الشعب الفلسطيني اسير تعسف الاحتلال ويؤكد
ان حل النزاعات سلميا شاق لكنه اقل كلفه
من
الحروب وسط تحذيرات متزايده من اضرار
بيئيه وصحيه لكارثه سيول شرق ليبيا مناطق
عازله وحواجز في درنا تحسبا لتفشي الامراض
الصحه العالميه تؤكد على اولويه توفير
مياه نظيفه عمليات مكثفه للعثور على
المفقودين وانتشال الجثث وجهود لاغاثه
المتضررين وفي المغرب استمرار عمليات
البحث عن ناجين وانتشال جثث ضحايا زلزال
الحوز لليوم الثاني عشر على التوالي جهود
مكثفه لايواء المنكوبين وعلاج الجرحى
والسلطات تعلن مواصله عمليات فتح الطرق
الجبليه المؤديه الى القرى النائيه
المتضرره
[موسيقى]
اعلنت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه ان ثلاثه
شبان فلسطينيين استشهدوا واصيب نحو 30
اخرين بنيران قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
التي هاجمت مدينه جنين ومخيمها وافاد شهود
عيان بان جنود الاحتلال حاصروا منزلا يعود
لعائله قائد كتائب شهداء الاقصى الذراع
العسكريه لحركه فتح احمد ابو البهاء وقد
استهدفوه بالقذائف الصاروخيه بينما قال
جيش الاحتلال انه استخدم طائره مسيره
مفخخه في تفجيره حيث تحصنت داخله مجموعه
من المسلحين ودارت اشتباكات عنيفه مع
الفلسطينيين تمكنوا باعتراف جيش الاحتلال
من تفجير لغم في احدى الياته لكنه نفى
وقوع اصابات واعلن جيش الاحتلال ان قواته
انسحبت من مدينه جنين ومخيمها بعد ان
اصابت عددا من المسلحين واعتقلت اثنين من
من وصفتهم بكبار
المطلوبين وقد نعت حركه حماس الشهداء
الذين سقطوا خلال اقتحام قوات الاحتلال
لمخيم جنين وقالت الحركه في بيان لها ان
الشهداء ارتقوا دفاعا عن شعبهم ومقدساتهم
واضافت ان كل جرائم الاحتلال بحق الشعب
الفلسطيني
ومقدساته لن تمر دون عقاب ولن تكسر ارادته
وصلابته معنا من رام الله مدير مكتب
الجزيره وليد العمري وليد ما طبيعه الموقف
الان وكيف تطور المشهد خلال الساعات
الفائته الان قوات الاحتلال بطبيعه الحال
انسحبت بالكامل من منطقه جنين ومن محيط
مخيمها التطور الذي حصل انها اعلن عن
اعتقاله شخصين تبين ان احدهما هو والد
احمد ابو البهاء قائد كتائب شهداء الاقصى
التابع لحركه فتح في مخيم الجنين وقد اصيب
بازمه قلبيه قبل ان يتم التجاوز حاجز
ومعسكر الجلمه على المدخل الشمالي لمدينه
جنين مما اضطر الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني
الى الاسراع في اعادته ونقله الى مستشفى
ابن سينا عدد الشهداء الثلاثه وعدد الجرحى
واكثر من 20 لكن بينهم اصابات خطيره لان
الكثير اصيبوا ايضا بعيرات ناريه اطلقتها
قوات الاحتلال باتجاه الراس بمعنى انه كان
هناك [__] استهداف الشهداء الثلاثه هم
مقاتلان والثالث هو مواطن عادي استشهد
بنيران قوات الاحتلال الموقف تطور على
النحو التالي قوات الاحتلال كعادتها ارسلت
مع ساعات المساء بعد ان ازدل الليل اي اي
وحل الظلام ارسلت قوات من المستعربين
الذين يتخفون بالزي المدني هؤلاء اكتشفهم
المقاومون يبدو انه كانت خشيه ومخاوف لدى
قوات الاحتلال من انهم قد يحاصروا وكانت
قد تاهب لارسال قوات مدرعه فارسلت نحو 40
من الياتها المصفحه والمدرعه من مدخلي
جنين الشمالي الذي ياتي من شارع الناصره
وحاجز ومعسكر الجلمه ومن المدخل الغربي
شارع حيفا ومعسكر وحاجز سالم ووصلت هذه
القوات جميعها الى محيط الناحيه الشرقيه
لمخيم جنين التي تتاخم مدينه جنين
واحيائها الغربيه مما ادارت اشتباكات
عنيفه مع المقاومين الفلسطينيين هناك
التوقيت الذي اختاره جيش الاحتلال لعمليته
هذه كان واضح انه في من ساعات الزحمه وهي
من الفترات التي يتواجد فيها المواطنون في
الش شوارع وفي تلك المناطق خاصه ان هذا هو
المدخل الرئيسي لمخيم الجنين
وقامت دارت هناك اشتباكات عنيفه قوات
الاحتلال قالت بانها استخدمت طائره مسيره
مفخخه فجرتها على مبنى كانت تحاصره في
المنطقه وايضا على مسجد طوالبه وا ودعت
بانه كان هناك مسلحين يتحصنون داخله ودارت
الاشتباكات اعترفت قوات الاحتلال بان احدى
ال ها قد انفجر
بها عبوه ناسفه القاها او زرعها المقاومون
الفلسطينيون لكنها لم تذكر وقوع اصابات
هذا يذكر بمرات سابقه حصل مثل ذلك وكانت
تعترف لاحقا بان هناك اصابات لكن هذه
المره حتى الساعه لم تعلن عن اي اصابات
وقالت بانها عمليتها هذه كانت تستهدف
بالاساس مطلوبا كبيرا ربما في اشاره الى
ابو البهاء وايضا الى مجموعه مسلحه يقودها
حسب
تعبيرها الفلسطينيون يقولون بان ابو
البهاء احمد ابو البهاء قد نجا وافلت من
قوات الاحتلال ولم تتمكن لا من اعتقاله
ولا من اصابته المصابون عدد كبير منهم من
المدنيين انفسهم بطبيعه الحال مخيم جنين
مستهدف بشكل كبير جدا من قبل قوات
الاحتلال منذ شهر نيسان العام الماضي اي
منذ اكثر من عام ونصف العام تقريبا وذلك
في اطار ما تصفها قوات الاحتلال بعمليه
كاسر الامواج التي تتواصل بدات في مخيم
الجنين ومحيطه و البلدات المحيطه ومن ثم
امتدت الى نابلس وبعدها الى طول كرم
واريحا تحديدا في مناطق شمالي الضفه
الغربيه وكان رئيس الحكومه الاسرائيليه
الموجود في نيويورك للمشاركه في افتتاح
الدوره الجديده للامم المتحده على اطلاع
متواصل ومنتظم بتطورات هذه العمليه التي
كان يشرف عليها وزير الدفاع جلنت ورئيس
الاركان
وقائد الشباك الاسرائيلي اي الجهاز الامن
العام لذا العمليه كانت مباغته ولكنها
استمرت لانه كانت هناك مقاومه كبيره من
قبل المقاومين الفلسطينيين شهود العيان
قالوا بان قوات احتلال استخدمت ايضا قذائف
الانر جا التي يتم اطلاقها عن الكتف
واستهدف احد المباني هناك الذي تبين انه
ايضا منزل تابع لعائله ابو البهاء نفسه
والمقاومون
الفلسطينيون الذين ينحدرون من كافه
الفصائل الفلسطينيه كانوا يتواجدون في
محيط المبنى وايضا في داخل المخيم نفسه
ووقوع هذا العدد الكبير من الشهداء
والاصابات يدل على ان تبادل اطلاق النار
والمعركه كانت قويه شكرا لك مديره مكتبنا
من رام الله وليد
العمري معنا من رامله الدكتور مصطفى
البرغوثي الامين العام
للمبادره الوطنيه الفلسطينيه دكتور مصطفى
مرحبا بك
معنا بطبيعه الحال هناك اهداف مباشره
لقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من خلال هذه
العمليات مثلا اليوم اعتقال
المطلوبين ولكن هناك اهداف ابعد من ذلك
ماذا وراء هذه العمليات المتتاليه
اولا الذي جرى اليوم هناك ثلاثه مؤشرات
مهمه اولا يجب ان نتذكر ان مخيم جنين
ومدينه جنين مثل كل الضفه الغربيه منطقه
تحت الاحتلال واليوم جيش الاحتلال المجرم
استخدم مدرعات بمثابه دبابات في الواقع
واستخدم طائرات بما في ذلك طائرات
الهيليكوبتر
واستخدم مسيرات محمله بالقنابل وقصف بها
المخيم واستخدم كل ما في جعب من صواريخ
واسلحه مختلفه ضد شعب تحت الاحتلال يعني
هذا قمه الاجرام ولكن هذا الهجوم الذي كان
هدفه المركزي في راي كسر المقاومه فشل فشل
من زاويتين الزاويه الاولى انه فشل في
اعتقال من كانوا يسعون
لاعتقاله المناضل ابو البهاء وثانيا فشل
لانه المقاومه تصدت بكل بساله والحقت
اضرار بما في ذلك تفجير مدرعه اسرائيليه
في قلب المخيم وانا اعتقد انه وقعت اصابات
وجيش الاحتلال يقوم باخفاء هذه الاصابات
ونسمع بعد العمليات عاده انباء عن قتلى
اسرائيليين جنود في حوادث طرق ولكن الاهم
من ذلك انه الهجوم الذي شنه الاحتلال في
تموز الماضي على مخيم جنين واجتياح بشكل
مدمر لم يحقق الهدف المرمي اليه وهو وقف
المقاومه الفلسطينيه وكسرها كل ما تقوم به
اسرائيل هدفه كسر اراده الشعب الفلسطيني
كسر مقاومه الشعب الفلسطيني وقف هذه
الوحده النضال الميدانيه الرائعه التي
يبديها المقاومون وهي تفشل المره تلو
الاخرى وستواصل الفشل ولن تذهب هذه
التضحيات الغاليه ثلاث شهداء و 30 جريح قد
يستشهد بعضهم ايضا لن تذهب هباء بل هي
تصنع طريق الحريه للشعب الفلسطيني التصدي
لهجوم الاح خلال يعني ايضا يواكب هذه
العمليات من وجهه نظرك كيف تبدو مواكبه
الفصائل الفلسطينيه لهذا الكم من العنف
والنيران
المتطوره التي يصبها جيش الاحتلال في كل
مره يقتحم فيها مدن الضفه
الغربيه هذا هو الاعجاز في الواقع انه
المقاومون طبعا هم يمتلكون اسلحه محد دوده
وخفيفه في الاساس
ويبتكرون بكل ما لديهم من طاقات نحن مناطق
محاصره يعني لا يوجد لنا حدود مفتوحه مع
اي دوله تدعم المقاومه ومع ذلك يبتكر
المقاومون والفلسطينيون كل الوسائل
الممكنه بما في ذلك حتى تصنيع العبوات
التي يستخدمونها ورغم هذه الامكانيات
المحدوده يقومون ببساله عظيمه
وبمقاييس
الحقيقه ان الرساله التي يرسلها هؤلاء
المقاومون لكل القيادات الفلسطينيه ان
عليكم ان ترتقوا الى مستوى هذا الاداء
النضالي الرائع وعليكم ان ترتقوا الى
مستوى الوحده التي يصنعها هؤلاء المناضلون
والمقاومون ضد هذا الاحتلال المجرم وفي
نهايه المطاف الصوره واضحه اسرائيل ترسل
كل يوم رساله واحده للشعب الفلسطيني انها
لا تفهم الى لغه القوه ولن ترتدع الا
بالمقاومه بالمقابل حاله الضغط والغلايات
هذه وحاله المقاومه المستمره ان كان من
قبل الفصائل والمقاومه
الشعبيه الى اي درجه تنتقل اصداؤها
الى المجتمع الدولي الذي يجتمع اليوم
بقادته في الامم
المتحده اخت سلمى ليس بشكل كافي بالتاكيد
والسبب هو تقاعس
المجتمع الدولي وتقصيره الفاضح واستخدامه
لمعايير مزدو
انظري يحتفون الان بزينس كي في الامم
المتحده ويتحدثون عن المقاومه في اوكرانيا
بكل الوسائل ويزودها بالسلاح ويصمت على
جرائم اسرائيل انا اتحدث بالاساس عن
القيادات الغربيه وعن الولايات المتحده
ولكن نحن منذ زمن بعيد لم نعد نراهن على
هؤلاء في الوقت الذي تتقاعس فيه الحكومات
وتتخذ عن نصره الشعب الفلسطيني وتطبيق
القانون الدولي نحن حقق كشعب فلسطيني
انتصارات عظيمه على مستوى الشعوب على
مستوى المجتمعات المدنيه وعلى مستوى تحول
كبير في الراي العام الدولي الذي يراه
عداله القضيه الفلسطينيه وسمعنا اليوم في
كلمات في الامم المتحده اشارات واضحه الى
النضال الوطني الفلسطيني اي بما في ذلك
الاشاره التي اوضحها امير قطر بان عمليا
اسرائيل لا تمارس فقط الاحتلال وانما
انشات منظومه ابار تيت عنصريه الاسوا في
تاريخ البشريه في القرن ال 21 وبالتالي
انا اعتقد ان مناصره القضيه الفلسطينيه
تتعاظم
ولكن الدول الغربيه بالاساس وحتى مؤسسات
الامم المتحده تبدي عجزا مطلقا عن تطبيق
القانون الدولي عندما يتعلق الامر بفلسطين
وبشعبان شكرا لك دكتور مصطفى البرغوثي
الامين العام للمبادره الوطنيه الفلسطينيه
شكرا على المشاركه معنا شكرا لك اعلنت
وزاره الصحه في قطاع غزه استشهاد شاب
فلسطيني واصابه 11 اخرين برصاص قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي خلال مسيرات في
المناطق الحدوديه شرقي القطاع وقد شارك
عشرات الشبان الفلسطينيين في مظاهرات
شعبيه نصره للمسجد الاقصى وتنديدا
بالاقتحام والانتهاكات الاسرائيليه واشعل
المتظاهرون الاطارات المطاطيه ورفعوا
اعلام فلسطين قرب السياج الامني قبل ان
تطلق عليهم قوات الاحتلال الرصاص الحي
وقنابل غاز المسيل للدموع
[موسيقى]
ننتقل الان الى مبنى الامم المتحده في
نيويورك وهذه النافذه مع خديجه بن جنا
اليك
خديجه شكرا سلمى اهلا بك وبمشاهدة
الامريكي جو بايدن قال ان ايران يجب ان لا
تمتلك ابدا السلاح او اسلحه النوويه
واتهم ايران بزعزع الامن الاقليمي
والعالمي واضاف الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
ان روسيا تتحمل مسؤوليه الحرب في اوكرانيا
وهي قادره على انهائها كما
قال
روسيا وحدها تتحمل مسؤوليه هذه الحرب
وروسيا وحدها قادره على انهاء هذه الحرب
فورا روسيا وحدها هي التي تقف في طريق
السلام لان الكلفه الروسيه للسلام هي
انصياع اوكرانيا والاستيلاء على اراضيها
واطفالها روسيا تعتقد ان العالم سيتعب
وسيسمح لها بمعامله اوكرانيا بوحشيه دون
عواقب علينا ان نقف في وجه العدوان الروسي
السافر اليوم لردع اي معتدين م تملين
اخرين في الغد وقال الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان قال ان بلاده تسعى
جاهده منذ بدايه الحرب في اوكرانيا لابقاء
الطرفين الروسي والاوكراني حول طاوله
المفاوضات واضاف اردوغان في كلمه له امام
الجمعيه العامه ان تركيا ستكثف جهودها
لانهاء الحرب من خلال الدبلوماسيه ومن
خلال الحوار على اساس استقلال اوكرانيا
ووحده
اراضيها منذ بدايه الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه سعينا جاهدين لابقاء اصدقائنا
الاوكرانيين والروس حول الطاوله مع فرضيه
ان الحرب لن يكون فيها فائزون ولن يكون في
السلام اي خاسر وسوف نكثف جهودنا لانهاء
الحرب من خلال الدبلوماسيه والحوار على
اساس استقلال اوكرانيا وسلامه اراضيها ومن
خلال مبادره البحر الاسود التي اطلقنا
بالتعاون مع الامم المتحده منعنا خطر حدوث
ازمه جوع عالميه من خلال ضمان ايصال
33 مليون طن من الحبوب عبر البحر الاسود
الى الاسواق العالميه الاى ان عدم تنفيذ
هذا الاتفاق بكافه عناصره جعل العالم
يواجه ازمه جديده وقد تم تمديد هذه
المبادره ثلاث مرات جزئيا بفض لجهودنا
لدينا خطه جديده يتم بموجبها ايصال مليون
طن اخرى من الحبوب الى البلدان التي هي في
امس الحاجه اليها في جميع انحاء
العالم وفي كلمته امام الجمعيه العامه
للامم المتحده قال العاهل
الاردني الملك عبد الله الثاني قال ان عام
2003 كان الاكثر دمويه بالنسبه للشعب
الفلسطيني خلال 15 عاما الماضيه وجدد
العهد الاردني دعوته الى اقامه دوله
فلسطينيه مستقله عاصمتها القدس
الشرقيه يمكننا ان نرى الشعب الاسرائيلي
يدافع ويعبر عن هويته الوطنيه ومع ذلك فان
الشعب الفلسطيني محروم من نفس الحق الشرط
الاساسي لذلك هو اقامه دوله فلسطينيه
مستقله قابله للحياه على خطوط الرابع من
يونيو عام
1967 وعاصمتها القدس الشرقيه والعيش الى
جانب اسرائيل في سلام وامن وازدهار تاخير
العداله والسلام جلب دورات لا نهايه لها
من
العنف وقال امير دوله قطر الشيخ تمي بن
حمد ال ثاني في كلمته امام الجمعيه العامه
للامم المتحده قال انه لا يجوز ان يبقى
الشعب الفلسطيني اسير تعسف الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي الاستيطاني واضاف امير دوله
قطر ان اسرائيل ترد على مبادره السلام
والتطبيع العربيه بمزيد من التعنت ومزيد
من الاستيطان وتهويد القدس وتشديد الخناق
على قطاع
غزه فلا يجوز ان يبقى الشعب الفلسطيني
اسير تعسف الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الاستيطاني
ورفض الحكومات الاسرائيليه المتعاقبه اي
حل سياسي عادلا وفق مبادئ الشرعيه الدوليه
ولا يغيب عنكم ان تقاعس المنظمات الدوليه
عن اتخاذ اجراءات ضد الاحتلال اتاح ويتيح
الفرصه لاسرائيل لكي تقوض اسس حل الدولتين
بالتوسع
والاستيطان حتى اصبح الاحتلال يتخذ شكلا
نظام فصل عنصري في وضح نهار القرن
الواح وقال امير دوله قطر الشيخ تمي بن
حمد الثاني في كلمته امام الجمعيه العامه
للامم
المتحده ان طريق حل النزاعات بالطرق
السلميه طويل وشاق ولكنه اقل تكلفه من
الحروب ان طريق حل النزاعات بالطرق
السلميه هو طريق طويل طويل وشاق لكنه اقل
كلفه من الحروب والتزامنا بمواصله جهودنا
في تيسير وصناعه السلام هو التزام مبدئي
وهو في صلب سياساتنا
الخارجيه وقال امير دوله قطر الشيخ تمي بن
حمد ال ثاني قال ان بلاده تدين الجرائم
المرتكبه ضد المدنيين في الخرطوم ودارفور
وتدعو لمحاسبه مرتكبيها وفيما يتعلق
بالوضع في ليبيا اعرب امير دوله قطر عن
دعم بلاده الدائم لمساعي الممثل الخاص
للامين العام للامم المتحده وجهوده لحل
الازمه في ليبيا اما بخصوص لبنان فقال
الشيخ تميم بن حمد الثاني قال ان دوله قطر
تؤكد ضروره ايجاد حل
للفراغ الرئاسي بعد ان بات الخطر محدقا
بمؤسسات الدوله في لبنان
نحن ندين الجرائم المرتكبه ضد المدنيين في
العاصمه الخرطوم وفي اقليم
دارفور وندعو لمحاسبه مرتكبيها كما ندعو
الى وقف القتال والاحتكام لصوت العقل
وتجنيب المدنيين تبعات القتال وفي لبنان
الشقيق حيث اصبح الخطر محدقا بمؤسسات
الدوله نؤكد على ضروره ايجاد حل مستداما
للفراغ السياسي وايجاد الاليات لعدم
تكراره وتشكيل حكومه قادره على تلبيه
تطلعات الشعب اللبناني والنهوض به من
ازماته الاقتصاديه والتنمويه وفي الشان
الليبي نؤكد دعمنا الدائم لمساعي الممثل
الممثل الخاص للامين العام ورئيس بعثه
الامم المتحده للدعم في ليبيا وجهوده
المبذوله لتحقيق نتائج ملموسه لحل الازمه
الليبيه وقال امير دوله قطر الشيخ تمي بن
حمد الثاني في كلمته امام الجمعيه العامه
للامم المتحده قال ان بلاده تجدد الدعوه
لتوحيد الجهود لمنع اساءه استخدام الفضاء
السبراني نجدد الدعوه لتوحيد الجهود لمنع
اساءه استخدام الفضاء السبراني وتنظيم هذا
الجانب الحيوي استنادا لاحكام القانون
الدولي
وفي هذا السياق ستنعقد في الدوحه قمه
الويب 20 24 ويشكل انعقادها فرصه هامه
لاستعراض التطور في مجال التكنولوجيا وخلق
فرص تعاون جديده في عالم التكنولوجيا
لصالح البشريه
جمعان وتنضم الينا من الامم المتحده
مراسله الجزيره بيسان ابو كويك بيسان اهلا
بك لو نلخص نعرج على يعني الكلمات التي
استمعنا اليها اليوم ما هي اهم هذه
الكلمات وما جاء
فيها ربما العنوان الرئيسي خديجه هو هذا
التاكيد على ضروره حل الصراعات المتعدده
التي يواجهها العالم اليوم اضافه الى
تغيرات المناخ والامن الغذائي سمعنا من
الرئيس بايدن يوجه تحذيرا للعالم بان
روسيا هي التي تتحمل وحدها مسؤوليه الحرب
في اوكرانيا داعيا دول العالم من عدم ربما
التودد الى روسيا ايضا في رسالته ربما
رساله ضمنيه ايضا داخليا هنا في الولايات
المتحده خصوصا مع بعض التململ ازاء الدعم
المقدم
لاوكرانيا ايضا سمعنا من الرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان الذي تحدث عن دور بلاده
في
مواصله يعني المفاوضات او ان يجلس
الاوكرانيين والروس على الطاوله وما كانت
بلاده ودورها في قضيه مبادره البحر الاسود
للحبوب الرئيس الاوكراني فلاديمير
زيلينسكي تحدث للمره الاولى بشكل شخصي
امام الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده قائلا
ان روسيا تخدم الطاقه والغذاء كسلاح
وقائلا ان الحرب في اوكرانيا هذه الحرب
الروسيه في اوكرانيا هي سلاح تستخدم ان
اوكرانيا واراضيها وشعبها يستخدم كسلاح ضد
العالم ايضا سمعنا كلمات من امير دوله قطر
الذي تطرق ايضا الى الحرب في اوكرانيا
وضروره حل هذه الصراعات تحدث عن الصراع في
السودان منددا بخسائر الارواح بين
المدنيين وطبعا قضيه الملف الفلسطيني
الصراع العربي الاسرائيلي كان له مكانه
كبيره في خطابه بالقول بان اسرائيل ترد
على مبادرات التطبيع بالمزيد من التعنت
الاستيطاني
وايضا تهويد
القدس العاهل الاردني الملك عبد الله
الثاني تحدث ايضا عن ضروره التوصل الى حل
ل القضيه الفلسطينيه متحدثا عن دور الاردن
في حمايه هويه القدس وما يرزح تحته
الفلسطينيين من احتلال
ايضا الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان تحدث
عن هذه القضيه بضروره ايجاد حل عادل وسلام
شامل للقضيه الفلسطينيه لذا قضايا متعدده
وكان في مجمل هذه الكلمات ايضا تشديد على
اهميه ايجاد واتخاذ خطوات لمواجهه التغير
المناخي خصوصا في ظل الكوارث الطبيعيه
المتعدده التي يشهدها العالم من زلازل
واعاصير وفيضانات وحرائق وايضا قضيه الامن
الغذائي سمعناها من عده قاعده في كلماتهم
هذا الخوف ربطها بحرب اوكرانيا وما ايه
يعني سمعناه من عده قاده بان روسيا تستخدم
الغذاء كسلاح ولكن ايضا ما يواجهه ايه
الكثر حول العالم الملايين او الالاف من
تهديد الجوع لذا عده كلمات كان لها وقع
خصوصا في ظل الصراعات المتعدده وما يراه
البعض هنا هو تهديد على النظام التعدديه
في العالم وانتهاك مطاق الامم المتحده
خصوصا ب
الحرب التي تشنها روسيا في اوكرانيا
خديجه بيسان ابوكويك شكرا جزيلا لك على كل
هذه التفاصيل كنت معنا من مقر الامم
المتحده ولخص لنا مختلف الكلمات التي
القاها القاده في هذه الدوره 78 للجمعيه
العامه للامم المتحده ما زلنا بصدد تحليل
الكلمات وينضم الينا هنا في مقر هذه
النافذه بالامم المتحده الخبير الاممي
الدكتور عبد الحميد صيام اهلا وسهلا بك
اهلا وسهلا
خديجه دكتور عبد الحميد صيام استمعنا في
كلمه بايدن جو بايدن الرئيس الامريكي الى
فكره
توسيع مجلس الامن الدولي هل ترى هذه
الفكره واقعيه هل المشكله في توسيع
العضويه ام في الفيتو وغياب التوافق في
القضايا الرئيسيه يعني هناك مشاكل حقيقيه
في المجتمع الدولي الان هناك في غياب
للتوافق
وتوسيع مجلس الامن اذا لم يكن هناك توافق
لا يمكن ان يتم توسيع مجلس الامن لان كل
دوله من الدول دائمه العضويه تريد ان تضم
اعضاء حلفاء لها الولايات المتحده منذ زمن
تريد اليابان والمانيا لان هاتين الدولتين
قريبتين من الولايات المتحده وهناك دول
تريد الهند ودول تريد البرازيل ودول تريد
دوله من دول افريقيا بشكل دائم العضويه
لكن هناك خلافات عندما تجتمع الدول الخمسه
دائمه العضويه لا يتفقون على واحد اثنين
ثلاث يعني كل يريد ان يقدم المرشحين الذي
الذين يانس بهم ويريده ان يكون طيب امريكا
تانس بمن تانس بالمانيا واليابان اساسا
وروسيا روسيا تريد دوله مثل نيجيريا او
مثل جنوب افريقيا بالتحديد مثلا اذا كل
يغني ل نعم كل يغني على ليله ثم نقطه مهمه
قد لا يعرفها الكثير ان المجموعات
الاقليميه تختلف فيما بينها على من يمثل
تلك المجموعه حتى المجموعات الايه مختل ن
مثلا في افريقيا نيجيريا تقدم نفسها
الدوله الاكثر اهليه لتمثيل القاره لانها
هي اكبر دوله لكن جنوب افريقيا لها تراث
تاريخي ومهم وهي صاحبه اقوى اقتصاد في
افريقيا هي ترى نفسها مؤهله اكثر من
نيجيريا وهناك الاخرى تنازع الدولتين مثل
مصر ايضا تريد ان
تجمع البعد الافريقي والبعد العربي والبعد
الاسلامي كذلك الجزائر ايضا لها
طموحات حتى القاره امريكا اللاتينيه
البرازيل ترشح نفسها لكن البرازيل لا
تتكلم اللغه الاسبانيه والقاره كلها تتكلم
اللغه الاسبانيه فيقولون كيف يمثلنا من لا
يتكلم لغتنا فهذه اشكاليات الهند تريد ان
تمثل القاره الاسيويه لكن تعط رض عليها
الباكستان واندونيسيا ودول اخرى مجموع
هناك
خلافات ثم الخلاف حول الفيتو ايضا يعني
هناك اقتراحات بان اذا تم توسيع مجلس
الامن وهو مستبعد ان يكون ايضا الفيتو يتم
تغييره بحيث يكون على الاقل على الاقل
يصوت ضد مشروع القرار دولتان من الدول
دائمه العضويه وثلاث دول من الدول غير
دائمه العضويه حتى يكون فيتو بحيث يصبح
الفيتو صعبا ويكون هنا توافق اكثر
ويتجنبون الفيتو الذي يستعمل صباح مساء
كما هو الحال
الان انتهى وقت هذه النافذه سنعود الى
الدوحه شكرا جزيلا لك الدكتور عبد الحميد
صيام الخبير الاممي عوده مره اخرى الى
الدوحه وسلمى هناك اليك
[موسيقى]
سلمى
شكرا لك خديجه الى ليبيا الان حيث تكافح
فرق الانقاذ للعثور على جثث ضحايا السيول
التي اجتاحت مدينه درنا في ظل تحذيرات
متزايده من الاضرار البيئيه والصحيه لتحلل
هذه الجثث والتفشي المحتمل للامراض نتيجه
ذلك في الاثناء اعلنت السلطات المحليه الى
تقسيم المدينه وفقا لحجم الضرر الذي
اصابها واقامت حواجز ومناطق عازله بينها
تحسبا لتفشي امراض كانت الامم المتحده قد
حذرت اخيرا من امكانيه تسببها فيما سمته
ازمه مدمره
ثانيه هذا واعلن جهاز المباحث المباحث
الجنائيه في ليبيا انتشال 38 جثه قذف بها
البحر قباله منطقه الفتائح شرقيه مدينه
درنا وذكر الجهاز على صفحته في فيسبوك انه
نسق جهوده مع غرفه العمليات بمدينه درنا
والاداره العامه لامن السواحل لانش شال
باقي الجثث التي تركز معظمها في اربعه
مواقع بساحل منطقه الفتائح مضيفا انه لا
يمكن الوصول الى تلك المناطق الا عن طريق
البحر نظرا لصعوبه التضاريس في تلك
المنطقه بدوره نفى ممثل منظمه الصحه
العالميه في ليبيا الدكتور احمد زويتن
امكانيه انتشار الاوبئه بسبب الجثث في
درنا واكد ان المهمه الاساسيه الان هي
توفير مياه نظيفه للمنكوبين
كثيرون يركزون على امكانيه نشر جثث الموتى
للاوبئه ولكن يجب ان اؤكد انه لا توجد اي
ادله على ذلك يمكن للاوبئه ان تنتقل فقط
في حاله اصابه الاشخاص بها قبل الوفاه مثل
الموت نتيجه الاصابه بابولا او غيرها ولكن
هذه ليست الحاله في درنا وفرصه حدوث ذلك
تكاد تكون منعدمه في
حالتنا قالت مصادر عسكريه ليبيه انه تم
نقل عشرات العسكريين والمسعفين العاملين
في مدينه درنا الى المستشفى بعد اصابتهم
باعراض اعياء واغماء واسهال وقيء ولم تكشف
تلك المصادر عن خلفيات الحادثه هذا وتجرى
تحريات وفحوصات معمقه للمصابين للكشف عن
الاسباب الحقيقيه لتلك
الاعراض لكل الوقوف على تطورات الوضع هناك
معنا من درنا مراسل الجزيره محمد البقالي
محمد ضعنا في اطار هذه الحوادث وما الذي
يقال عنها وايضا يعني وضح لنا حاله العزل
التي تطال بعض المناطق والحواجز من اجل
التخفيف من المخاطر المحتمله من تفشي اي
امراض او
اوبئه سلمى يمكن ان نقول ان خبر دخول
عشرات العسكريين الى المستشفى بسبب
اصابتهم با راض مثل الاسهال والقيء وغيرها
كان في الحقيقه مثيرا للقلق بل يمكن ان
اقول انه كان مثيرا للفزع لان الامر لا
يتعلق فقط بالعسكريين ولكن ايضا بعناصر
انقاذ وبمسح فين ومتطوعين وبالتالي
فتم تم استبعاده فرضيه التسمم لان الامر
يتعلق بافراد لا يشتركون في السكن والماكل
وغير ذلك ولكن وزير الصحه في الحكومه
المكلفه من البرلمان عقد مؤتمرا صحفيا ق
قبل قليل وقال ان الامر لا يتعلق بحاله
وبائيه وانما يتعلق بحاله قد تحدث بالنسبه
للذين يتعاملون في موضوع الانقاذ وخاصه في
استخراج الجثث وهو بذلك يرسل رساله تطمين
بان الامور ما زالت تحت السيطره هذا
التصريح في الحقيقه ينسجم محمد اتوقف معك
هنا ننتقل الى نيويورك وهذه الكلمه للرئيس
الايراني ابراهيم رئيس امام الجمعيه
العامه للامم
المتحده السلام عليكم بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين وصلى الله على نبينا
محمد فبشر عباد الذين يستمعون القول
فيتبعون
احسنه ا رئيس انتخاب جناب عال را به رست
هفتاد وهشم نشست مجموع عموم سازمان ملل
متحد تبر
مو از سال
قبل من
از اهنئكم
جميعا على
الدوره للجمعيه العامه للامم
المتحده منذ العام الماضي عندما تقدمت بخط
امام هذا الجامع
الكريم شهد العالم تطورات جيده وتطورات في
غايه
صعوبه بعد مرور عقود ثمانيه على انشاءه
الامم
المتحده تبدا الدوره الجديده للجمعيه
العامه اذ يخوض العالم تطورات وتغيرات
جذريه مستقبل البشريه ستند على يستند الى
الوفاء بافار نبيله
تسترشد بها البشريه
بهلام رورد
متعال متوان
انسان كلمات
الله هي التي
تجسد القيم الاصيله لجنس
البشر السيدات
والساده القران
الكريم يحث البشريه على تحكيم العقل على
التزام بالعداله
والحق ر
اسا
قرآ القران يؤكد على وحده
البشريه
تر فهو يوجه الجمع نحو الرامه
الانسانيه
والتي ستؤدي للبشريه الى تطلعات التي تصب
اليها ما الذي ورد في القران
الكريم
لاخاب من يتحكمون في السلطه با رهن توان
جهان ازمت ورد القران
ال ان الناس لا يقبلون
القمع
همهم وم ان نرقى الى النبل
الالهيه المثل النبي
الالهيه اذا ما التزمنا بهذا
المبدا ورد القران ان الناس قد خلق اسوء
وج
ت ينحرون كلهم من ادم وحواء بالرغم من ان
هناك فوارق طبيعيه بين النساء والرجال يرد
في القران ان الناس جميعهم اسوياء
في عين الله القران يدافع عن حرمه
الاسر
والاطفال هديه منحها
رب
و يحثون القران الكريم على
خدمه من
هم
اقل
سرا علينا ان نحافظ على هذه
القيم هل هذه هي المره الاولى خرقت فيها
كلمات
الله من يحرقون كلمات الله من يحرقون
القران الكريم هل يعتقدون انهم سيقضون على
هذه الكلمات
الخالده ابو و
ع هل حرق
القران سيلغي
كلمات موسى وعيس
ومحمد القران يحضر جميع انواع العنف في
المعاملات
الانسانيه وجود رسول خدا محمد صل الله عله
و آله
ولم
فاحترام الانبياء ابراهيم وموسى
وعيسى يعد على نفس مستوى الاحترام الذي
علينا ان نكنه للنبي محمد صلى الله عليه
وسلم
مفاه وحدت
بخش و تعال
مت هذه
القيم والتعليم الاسلاميه هي التي تؤدي
الى الوحده هي التي تبني الشخصيه هي التي
تبني
المجتمعات هي التي تمهد الطريق نحو التقدم
للمجتمعات البشر هه التم وهذه القيم لن
تحرق ابدا هي تعاليم خالده
زمان
باق آتش
توه و
تحف حف
حققت نواهد
ش ان
لهب
الجهل لن يحل محل
الحق سيدي الرئيس كراهيه
الاسلام والفصل الثقافي الذي نشهده في
المجتمعات الغربيه والذي تجلى
في منع الحجاب في
المدارس وتدنيس القران وانواع اخرى من
التمييز
المستهجن
هذه الممارسات لا تستحق انول
اهتمام خلف الكواليس يبدو ان هناك
مخطط يسعى الى صرف
الانتباه عما
يجري باستخدام حريه التعبير فقد قال احدهم
ان الغرب يواجه ازمه هويه قال احد ممثلي
الغرب ان الغرب يواجه ازمه هويه ويرى ان
العالم غابه وينصب نفسه على انه وصي على
هذه
الغابه فرهن جامعه مسلمانان بخصوص مهاجران
را هدف قرار
رفته هذه الممارسات قد استهدفت الجاليات
المسلمه خاص خصه المهاجرين الذين وقعوا
ضحيه للممارسات
الاستعماريه نحن ندعو الى
الحريه وينبغي ان احترام الاديان ينبغي ان
يتصدر قائمه الاولويات في الامم
المتحده لضمان احترام جميع الاديان
السماويه نواجه الان حربا على الاسلام
وفي نفس الوقت نواجه حربا على
الاسره
هي
دعامه التقدم البشري الدعامه التي
تتعرض للهجوم الجرائم ضد الانسانيه الان
لا تشمل جرائم الحرب الجماعيه وقمع الشعوب
فهي تشمل الان الهجوم على الاسره وهذه
جريمه ضد
الانسانيه حمايه نواه المجتمع امر مهم
نواه المجتمع نتيجه ليجه بين رجل وامراه
هذه حقيقه اصيله على العالم باجمعه
انقبل
بها در حققت تلاش برا
حذف مفاه متعال نظر
مادر فاذا ل نتم بهه التعليم لن نحقق
النتائج المرجوه هذه الكلمات الالهيه الام
الاب المفاهيم الطبعيه مثل
[موسيقى]
الاسره رودها وظفه انسان ما ما امروز
نزم اي تهجم على هذه المفاهيم يعد تهجما
على الانسانيه نحن بحاجه الى حركه عالميه
تاتي
بالتزام
باطار
الاسره حتى تتمكن جميع الاسر من العيش
بسلام وامن ولذلك نطالب جميع القاضى
الدينيين بالوفاء بمسؤوليتهم التاريخيه
حيه قدسيه الاسره ومناهض اي اي فبركه
ونتوقع من الامم
المتحده ان تولي اهتماما خاصا لهذه
المساله وان تقدم حمايه لاطار الاسره
السيدات والساده نجد انفسنا في لحظه حاسمه
في التاريخ المشهد التاريخي كذلك يمر
بمرحله تحول نحو
نظام
ناشئ وهو ما صار لا يمكن العدول
عنه هيمنه الغرب لا تتماشى مع واقع العالم
المعاصر النظام الليبرالي القديم الذي يصب
في مصلحه
حكام طماعين كل ذك بائ هذا النظام اصبح
بائ وعفى عليه الزمن هذا النظام قد سعى
الى عولم القيم الامريكيه والامه
الايرانيه
تفخر
بانها خاضت ثوره
اسلاميه ولعبت بذلك دورا مهما
[موسيقى]
لهزيمه التعنت
والكبرياء الغربي ظهرت على الساحه قوى غير
غربيه ولذلك هناك امل لاقامه نظام جديد
ومنصف على الصعيد
العالمي في صلب هذا النظام الجديد يقع
التخلص من التعنت
والقرفه لصالح التعاون جمهوريه ايران
الاسلاميه تدعو الى تحولات اقتصاديه
وسياسيه في ما بين المناطق وفي كل منطقه
على
حده ندعو الى التعاون مع المجتمع الدولي
على اساس مبدا
العداله الدول
المستقله بشكل متزايد تؤيد
التعاون
وبعض الدول الاخرى تسعى
الى نشر الفتن في مناطق
مختلفه هذه الدول تسعى الى وضع عراقيل على
الصعيد العالمي وهذه المساعي تمثل تهديدا
لامن وازدهار الامم جمهوريه ايران
الاسلاميه
تتمسك باهميه عدم السماح بفجوه كبيره بين
كتلتين الغرب
والشرق تحويل الحلفاء الى
[موسيقى]
دول تابعه نشر الحروب الوكاله في اوروبا
وفي اسيا كلها عناصر لهذه الممارسات
الاثمه وللمفارقة
ولكن المجتمع الدولي بما في ذلك دول في
غرب اسيا
قد
اكتشفت حقيقه الديمقراطيات الغربيه التي
تسعى الى الانقلابات وتسعى الى اطاله امد
الحروب الطبيعه الاساسيه لمشروع
الديمقراطيه اصبح واضحا
للجميع هو
قفاز
جان ح عبرت تبل شده و بهان راه
خود فقد
اصبحت اوجه قصور هذا النظام واضحه للجمع
السيدات
والساده بعض القوى توجه العالم نحو مزيد
من الحروب اما ايران فقد وضعت
سياسه
لحسن الجوار وهذه
السياسه تول الاولويه للخطط الاقليميه
جمهوريه ايران الاسلاميه
ترحب بكل يد
ممدوده بروح الصداقه
ومن جمه
اسلام دوست درا ش استقرار المنطقه يصب في
مصلحه جميع دول المنطقه نرحب
ده ترح
[موسيقى]
حارا فا استقرار دول الجوار صب في مصلحه
استقرار
المنطقه لقد علنا عقودا من التطور
منطقتنا ص تشهده سور و فلسط والمن
وافغانستان همها اقت
يوضح ان مستقبل المنطقه سيد حسن من خلال
الثقه المتبادله وتعزيز التعاون الاقتصادي
ووضع تدابير
امنيه ووفقا
لهذه
الرؤيه قمنا بالتعاون مع الدول متقاربه
التفكير في الجوار من خلال اليات اقليميه
ودوليه راذر تجار از جمله راذر شمال
جونده مثل منظ
شون الممر الاقتصادي الشمالي الشرقي قمنا
باء الاولويه لهذه التطورات الاستفاده من
هذه الاليات ليستفيد منها جميع دول
المنطقه جمهوريه ايران الاسلاميه كذلك
مستعده
انتقال انر هاا با رشور به اشترا
بذار ستغلال امكاناتنا لانطق الطاقه
المتجدده وتشاطر ذلك مع دول اخرى في
القطاع الامني سياسه حسن الجوار
تسعى الى زياده التعاون
الاقليمي وتحضر اي تدخل خارجي من القوقاز
الى الخليج الفارسي اي اي تواجد اي
وجود اجنبي لا يمثل جزءا من الحل بل يمثل
جوهر المشكله من القوقاز الى الخليج
الفارسي اي وجود اجنبي لا يعد
فقط لا يعد جزءا من الحل فحسب هو اصل
المشكله امن الدول المجاوره جزء من امننا
واي امن بالنسبه لدول الجوار هو جزء من
امننا
بالرحمه وبحسن النيه اطلقنا مبادرات في
المنطقه بالرغم من ان علينا ان نعزز بين
الجانب السياسي والجانب الامني وسنحقق
النجاح اذا ترافقت هذه العمليات بتعاون
اقتصادي حقيقي منطقه غرب اسيا وبسبب هجمات
عسكريه مستمره والاحتلال المستمر حرمت من
فرص متعدده للتقدم
والتنميه واليوم تحت قياده المشد
الاعلى
خانئ في
ايران تمكنا من التخلص من الاسس الفاسده
للارهاب استحدثنا فرصا جديده للمنطقه
ا
فجمهور ايران الاسلاميه تدفع
بالامن ونسعى الى مدي يد العون لدول
المجاوره حتى نستشف افاقا جديده من الامل
والنجاح للمنطقه باكملها نحن نؤمن بان هذه
الجهود جهود جماعيه في العالم
الاسلامي وهذا يتطلب مشاركه الجميع وهذا
هو سبيل الوحيد
للمضي قدما ولتحقيق النجاح في منطقه غرب
اسيا جمهوريه ايران
الاسلاميه لديها الكثير من الفرص النادره
للاستثمار وهي فرص ممتازه لدول العالم
ودول المنطقه السيدات والساده العام
الماضي كان عام
انتصار شعب ايران على الدول الغربيه
برا ار ر قدرت ملت ا لقد اقترف خطا فادح
نتيجه لسوء
تقدير سعى الى التقليل من شان شعب ايران
منذ الثوره الاسلاميه حققنا النصر تحت
قياده خمان اعداء
ايران
خططوا
فرض ارادتهم علينا وقد هزمنا هذه السياسات
الشعب الايراني قد هزم هذه السياسات
وانتصر مره طلو الاخرى والان هؤلاء
الاعداء يواجهون جمهوريه
اسلاميه تقدمها قائم على اواصر وثيقه مع
الشعب خلال العام الماضي شهد شعب ايران
موجه كبيره من حرب نفسيه شنت
ضده الولايات المتحده الامريكيه والتي
تملك
الان
اكبر سجن
للنساء تزعم بانها مدافع عن حقوق
النساء والصوره التي سعدت الولايات
المتحده
الى نقل هذا العالم من ايران
تم
ان مشروعه بانبا
مبر خلطت
الواقع
ا هل سمعتم اي شيء عن الانفجار الكيميائي
ضد الشعب الايراني الاسلحه الكيميائيه
التي امدت بعض الدول الغربيه لصدام حسين
هل سمعتم اي شيء عن من عانوا من هذا
الهجوم الكيميائي الذين بقوا على قد
الحياه ولكن ظلوا في المستشفيات لمده تزيد
عن 35 عاما هل رايتم صور هذه الفضائح هل
رايتم صور الاطفال الذين لا
يتمكنون
من مكافحه
امراض الجهاز المناعي بسبب
الى الادويه نتيجه للجزئ المفروض علينا هل
رايتم صور التضحيه والصمود والمثابره
والقوه لشعب جمهوريه ايران
الاسلاميه هل
ر مختل راه عظ ارع حس در
عراق هل
رايتم الحركه غير
بوقه لاحياء
ذكرى الامام حسين حفيد النبي
محمد الالاف قد توجهوا الى مقبره
بمناسبه
استشهاده
حامل الكثير من انجازاتنا في المنطقه جاءت
نتيجه
لتضحيات القائد
السليماني فهو كان بطل
تدابير مكافحه
الارهاب الكثير من دول المنطقه لكانت قد
سويت بالارض بسبب النيران التي اضرمها
تنظيم
داعش
والقاعده هل
تتذكرون قصص مكافحه الارهاب
البطوليه حا
قامل هل رايتم الجنازه التي شملت 25 مليون
شخص كناسه
القائد القاسم
سليماني كل هذه الصور قد خضعت لرقابه ولم
يتم بث هذه الصور في الاعلام
الغربي
اغتياله كان فعلا ارهابيا خدم كجائزه
لتنظيم داعش على طبق من
فضه استشهاد قاسم سليماني كان هديه لتنظيم
داعش فبدلا من الاعتراف ببطولته تم
اغتياله ولكن جمهوريه ايران الاسلاميه ومن
خلال استخدام جميع القدرات والادوات عامل
و
مران ترسم دولت تا حصول نتجه سعت الى
مسائله المسؤولين وكل من ساهم في هذا
الفعل
الارهابي المسؤولون عن هذا الفعل الارهابي
سيخضعون
للمسائله لن
ننسى دم
الشهيد
ولن نتوقف عن مسائله المسؤولين السيدات
والساده الساده رساء الدول والحكومات
معظم ادات
الجسيمه في غرب اسيا تتمثل في الراديكاليه
والتطرف العنيف نواجه تحدي القضاء على
الارهاب من خلال مكافحه واسعه النطاق
ضد الاسباب الجذريه
للارهاب ان الاستخدام الانتقائي والجراحي
للارهاب من قبل حكومات غربيه بعينها كاداه
سياسيه ذلك سنتجاوز من خلال الاراده
الجماعيه لدول
المنطقه بعض الاجهزه الامنيه والاجهزه
الاستخباراتيه لدول
غربيه تنقل الارهاب من منطقه الى اخرى من
مكان الى اخر في
المنطقه
للاستفاده من القدره الفتاكه للارهاب هزار
نفر از شهروند اان را در خبان
تر نسال الدول الغربيه لماذا قدمتم ملاذا
امنا
لمجموعات
ارهابيه ايديها ملطخه بدماء 17 الف من
الايرانيين لماذا يتصرف الاوروبيون على
هذا النحو لابد لهم ان
يقدموا اجابه
وجيهه فهم يزعمون انهم يكافحون الارهاب
ولكنهم يقدمون ملاذا امنا للارهابيين
للمجموعات الارهابيه المعترف
بها
هذا هذه هي ازدواجيه
المعايير
ايران استهدفها الارهاب ولكنها كانت في
طليعه الدول لمكافحه الارهاب في
المنطقه شعوب المنطقه ترى ايران كشريك
لضمان
الامن
والنظام
المحتل في
القدس هو مصر الارهاب
الاساسي الم يحن الوقت لانهاء احتلال
الاراضي الفلسطينيه الم يحن الوقت لوقف
القضاء على منازل الفلسطينيين الم يحن
الوقت للاعراف فل كدوله
مستقله ل الم يحن وقف النظام الصهيوني من
احتلاله لاراضي لبنانيه
وسوريه
وفلسطينيه لقد تم انكار حق الفلسطينيين
الاصلي في اقامه
دولتهم لابد من تشكيل حكومه فلسطينيه
مشروعه الدوله اليه غ ان تكون
القدس بعض
الحكومات تستغل النظام الصهيوني
كاداء
ح وضعت اسس معينه في المنطقه من قبل دول
معينه على اساس اكاذيب على اساس التدمير
والاحتلال هذه الدول لا يمكن ان تكون
شريكه في السلام الوضع في افغانستان اليوم
يمثل مثالا اخر للتدخل الخارجي في المنطقه
الذ الذي ادى الى مقتل اكثر من 70 ال من
النساء والرجال والاطفال في افغانستان
و تصر ايران على حكومه شامله
بمشاركه جميع الافغان جميع الفصائل
الافغانيه ولكننا بحاجه الى مساعده
المجتمع الدولي للتصدي لازمه اللائقين
اللاجئين الذين اكبروا على مغادره ارضهم
في
افغانستان ونحن نقدم ملادا امنا في ايران
لهؤلاء اللاجئين فيما يتعلق بالازمه
الاوكرانيه والحرب في اوكرانيا اود ان
اذكر الجميع مره اخرى بموقفنا الواضح
والراسخ جمهوريه ايران الاسلاميه لا تدعم
اي حرب اينما كانت لا في اوروبا ولا في اي
مكان
اخر ما من حرب يمكنها ان تفيد اي جانب
توت وا استخدام ل
العنف في اوكرانيا كان ناجم
عن خطوات الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
لاضعاف الدوله الاوروبيه وهذه خطه طويله
الامد للاسف نحن ندعم اي
مبادره لوقف الاعمال
العدائيه لوقف الحرب
وندعم اي تدبير سياسي
نحن ندعم
تماما هذا النوع من التدابير والمبادرات
سيدي الرئيس اي السيدات
والساده
الامريكيون غادروا خطه العمل الشامله
المشتركه وداسوا بذلك على التزامات هذه
الاداره
الامريكيه كانت استغا غير مقبوله لوفاء
نحن بالالتزامات الوارده في هذه الخطه من
خلال الانسحاب من هذا
الاتفاق في اطار القرار 2231 الذ اعتمده
مجلس
الامن ارتبت الولايات المتحده جريمه بغيضه
واححد الجانب في المشهد العالمي الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ينبغي ان تشرحه بشكل
شفاف مسر دارد اروها نز در سالها عدم
باابن
ان تثبت انها ترغب في تسويه هذه المساله
ينبغي لولايات المتحده ان تختار طريقا اما
خطه العمل الشامله مشتركه او
ز م
رعت والدول الاوروبيه التي تتجاهل قرار
مجلس الامن
231 وتتجاهل التزاماتها بموجب خطط العمل
الشامن المشتركه تلك الدول الاوروبيه كذلك
سيخسرون
تاكدوا ان الاسلحه النوويه لا مكان لها في
العقيده العسكريه والدفاعيه لجمهوريه
ايران
الاسلاميه فعديد من المنظمات الدوليه
اصدرت تقارير اقرت بذلك جمهوريه ايران
الاسلاميه وكما فعلت قبل عقدين من
الزمان
لن تتنازل عن حقها في الحصول على طاقه
نوويه تستخدم للاغراض
السلميه لقد اوفينا
بالتزاماتنا ولكن للاسف الولايات
المتحده لا تكتفي فقط بعدم الوفاء
بالتزاماتها بموجب الفاقات العالميه مثل
مهده عدم الانتشار بل هي تفرض جزاءات دام
هذه
الذريعه تفرض جزاءات على شعب ايران اليوم
اقول لكم ان الجزاءات لم تاتي بالنتائج
المرجوه ان الاوان الولايات المتحده ان
تتوقف عن فرض هذه
الجزاءات
فهي تسير على المسار الخاطئ السيدات
والساده تدخل البشريه فصلا جديدا القوى
القديمه
[موسيقى]
ستستمر في دوامه لا نهايه لها هذه القو
القديمه تمثل الماضي ونحن نمثل المستقبل
هذه الدول القديمه اكرر تمثل الماضي ونحن
نمثل
المستقبل رؤيتنا للمستقبل رؤيه مليئه
بالامل
العالم بانتظار
الوم
الذ وعدتنا به جمع الاان
السماويه
مش نحن نؤمن بانه وفقا
للاراده الالهيه كما وعدنا
الانبياء الحق
سيسود حم فرما و بشرت با رشد آاه
نا ومن سار صراط
[موسيقى]
مستق هو الذي سينهض بهذا العالم عالم
يرفض الجهل العالم بانتظار هذا
اليوم سينته العهد القم اشر جمعا على حسن
الانتباه السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته
بنيابه عن الجمعيات العامه اتوجه بالشكر
الى صاحب الفخامه رئيس جمهوريه ايران
الاسلاميه
واطلب الى القائمين على مراسم مرافقه
فخامته ستستمع الجمعيات العامه الان الى
خطاب يلقيه صاحب الفخامه السيد عبد المجيد
تبون رئيس الجمهوريه الجزائريه
الديمقراطيه الشعبيه اطلب من القائمين على
المراسم مرافقه
فخامته انه لم دواع شرفي وسروري ان ارحب
بصاحب الفخمه السيد عبد المجيد تبون رئيس
الجمهوريه الديمقراطيه
الشعبيه للجزائر وادعو لخطبه الجمعيه
العامه بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم والصلاه والسلام على اشرف
المرسلين
معالي السيد رئيس الجمعيه
العامه معالي السيد الامين العام للامم
المتحده اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه
والسمو السيدات
والساده في هته
المناسبه يسعدني ان اتوجه بالتحيه
والتقدير لاصحاب
الفخامه والجلاله والسمو قاده الدول
ورؤساء الوفود المشاركين في الدوره الثامن
والس لجمعيه للجمعيه العامه للامم
المتحده كما
يسعدني ان اتوجه باصدق عبارات التهاني الى
السيد دينيس
فرانسيس على توليه رئاسه
الدوره متمنيا له النجاح
والتوفيق في مهامه الساميه معربا كذلك عن
تقديري لجهود السيد
كسبا
كورسي رئيس الدوله السابقه الدوره
السابقه كما
اسدي خالص
الشكر وبالغ التقدير لمعالي الامين العام
للامم
المتحده السيد انطونيو
جوتيريش مجددا دعم
الجزائر لجهوده
الحثيثه والجدير
بالثناء لتعزيز دور منظمتنا والنهوض بها
بما يستجيب لتطلعات
الشعوب سيد
الرئيس ان في هته القاعه التي تسع العالم
باسره
وتنوعه
واختلافه نطمح
الى ان تترسخ في قناعتنا
جميعا بان الحوار
والنقاش بيننا مطلب ملح ناضلت من اجله
شعوبنا من اجل عالم
التعايش
والتعاون
والتضامن والمساواه بين الامم
ومن
هنا ناضلت بلادي منذ حوالي 50 سنه خلت ومن
هذا المنبر
بالذات عن مكامن الخلل في النظام الدولي
الحالي ودعت الى نظام دولي
جديد تكون فيه
المساواه بين الدول التي تاسست من اجلها
منظمه الامم المتح
محده سيد
الرئيس بلغت النزاعات والازمات في العالم
مستوى غير
مسبوق شردت الملايين من الاشخاص
وحولت العلاقات الدوليه من علاقات تعاون
وتوافق الى مواجهه
وصدمات وضعت الهيئات والمؤسسات الدوله على
المحك في
وقت يشهد فيه العالم حاله
طوارئ ضاغطه مناخيه
وغيرها وامام هته الصراعات
الجيوسياسيه والازمات
المتعدده ضعف مجلس الامن في السنوات
الاخيره في دوره المحور الذي قامت عليه
الامم
المتحده والذي
لخص
الميثاق ميثاق الامم المتحده اهم مقاصده
في تحميله مسؤوليه حفظ السلم والامن
الدوليين لا
سما من خلال منع اللجوء الى القوه وازاله
الاسباب التي تهدد السلم بالاضافه الى
التسويه السلميه
للنزاعات لقد حان
الوقت التفكير
معا في سبل اعلاء قيم ومبادئ مثق الامم
المتحده
وتعزيز التزاماتنا
الجماعيه وارساء
الاسس المتينه التي تفضي الى المزيد من
التعاون العالمي الفعال بشان القضايا
الرئيسيه حتى
نتمكن من اشعاع السلم والامن الدوليين
وتحقيق اهداف التنميه المستدامه في ظل
عالم متعدد
الاقطاب ومن هذا المنظور فان
الجزائر التي ت
تتاهب
لتبوء مقعدها غير الدائم بمجلس الامن تعي
ثقه المسؤوليه الملقاه على
عاتقها بال للتحديات
الجمه التي تواجهها المجموعه
الدوليه واغتنم هته
السانحه لاجدد الشكر لكل
الدول ال
184 التي صوتت لصالح بلادي وهي
ثقه
س تحرص الجزائر على صونها اثناء عهدتها
بالمجلس وستسعى على تجسيدها بالتعاون
الوطيد في مع كافه الدول الاعضاء في مجلس
الامن وفي هيئه الامم
المتحده وتسخير خبره
الجزائر الثريه في مجال الوساطه وتغليب
الحلول السياسيه والتسويه السلميه
للنزاعات
وعمل بهته
الروح فان بلادي ستنضم الى مجلس
الامن حامله لتطلعات شعوب القاره
الافريقيه والعالم العربي وداعيه الى
تجاوز منطق تسيير الازمات بل اعتماد
مقاربه ترتكز على الحلول
النهائيه للازمات
من خلال معالجه اسبابها
الجذريه سيد
الرئيس ان اي مسعى لتعزيز العمل الدولي
المشترك يقتضي منا الاستجابه للنداءات
المتزايده بصوره اعطاء ديناميكيه اكثر
للنظام متعدد
الاقطاب عبر اصلاح الاجهزه الرئيسيه
للمنظم
اصلاحا
شاملا من
شانه ان يجعلها اكثر
شفافيه ويحقق التوازن الضروري ما بين
الاجهزه الرئيسيه ويكفل التوازن
الجغرافي
العادل
وعليه
فان تنشيط الدور المركزي للجمعيه العامه
للامم
المتحده باعتباره الجهاز الوحيد المعبر
بصدق عن تنوع مكونات المجموعه الدوليه هو
عامل جوهري في تعزيز المساواه بين الدول
وتكريس اسس الديمقراطيه
الحقه كما ان
الدفع بعجله
المفاوضات الدوليه الحكوميه بشان اصلاح
مجلس
الامن وفق منهج متكامل
وشامل
ينبغي ان يكون
اولويه للمجموعه
الدوليه بغيه التواصل الى توافق حول اصلاح
حقيقي اكثر تمثيل
وشفافيه وهو ما يدعو هنا الى التاكيد على
التزام الجزائر بالموقف الافريقي الموحد
بما يضع
حدا للاج احاف التاريخي في حق القاره
الافريقيه سيد
الرئيس ان الجزائر التي تعي
جدا ثمن انتزاع
الحريه لن تتخلى عن مسانده القضايا
العادله ودعم الشعوب
المضطهده التي تكافح من اجل التحرر ومن
هذا منطلق سعه على الدوام الى دعم القضيه
الفلسطينيه لتمكين الشعب الفلسطيني
الشقيق من حقوقه غير القابله
للتصرف في اقامه دولته المستقله على حدود
الرابع من جوان 67 وعاصمتها القدس
الشريف طبقا لقرارات الشرعيه الدوليه
وكتعبير عن موقفها ودعمها للقضيه
الفلسطينيه العادله بادرت بلادي نهايه
السنه
الماضيه باشراف شخصي بعقد
مؤتمر للم الشمل من اجل توحيد الفصاء
الفلسطينيه تكلل باعتماد اعلان
الجزائر واود في هذا
السياق ان اعرب مجددا عن تمك تمسكنا
بمبادره السلام
العربيه كاطار لتسويه القضيه
الفلسطينيه وانهاء
الاحتلال الذي يعد السبب الجوهري لعدم
الاستقرار منطقه الشرق
الاوسط مهيبا بالضمير الحي للمجتمع
الدولي ان يتحمل المسؤوليه الاخلاقيه
والتاريخيه من اجل تمكين الش الشعب
الفلسطيني من تقرير مصيره واسترجاع حقوقه
كامله غير منقوصه ومن جهه
اخرى اغتنم هته الفرصه لادعو ومحكمه العدل
الدولي الى الاستجابه لطلب الجمعيه العامه
لمنظمه الامم
المتحده المؤرخه في 30 ديسمبر 22 2022
باصدار رايها الاستشاري حول
الممارسات التي تمس حقوق الانسان في
الاراضي
الفلسطينيه المحتله بما فيها القدس
الشريف
متطلعا معكم الى انتصار الحق وانصاف كفاح
الشعب
الفلسطيني الذي طالت تضحياته
ومعاناته من مظالم
الاحتلال
كما ادعو من هذا المنبر مجلس الامن الى
اصدار
قرار يؤكد
بموجبه حمايه الحل
الدولتين التي يحضى باجماع
دولي
ووقف الاعمال احاديه الجانب للسلطه
القائمه على الاحتلال وعلى راسها الانشطه
الاستيطانيه في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه
في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
المحتله مع تجديد
المطالبه والح على ذلك تجديد المطالبه
بعقد جمعيه عامه
استثنائيه لمنح دوله فلسطين العضويه
الكامله فيها
واكرر مع تجديد المطالبه بعقد جمعيه عامه
استثنائيه لمنح دوله فلسطين العضويه
الكامله في الجمعيه العامه للامم
المتحده اننا
نعتز بنجاح منظمتنا في انهاء الاستعمار في
العديد في العديد من المناطق والاقاليم
ونتطلع الى الوصول الى تصفيه نهائيه
لظاهره الاستعمار مع اخر مستعمره افريقيه
حيث لازال شعب باكمله في الصحراء
الغربيه محروما من حقه الاساسي في تقرير
المصير عبر استفتاء حر
ونزيه
يتوافق مع خطه التسويه الامميه
الافريقيه التي
اعتمدتها اعتمدها مجلس الامن سنه
1991 ووافق عليها الطرفان والتي تظل تنتظر
التطبيق وفي ظل هذا
الواقع
وفي وامام المحاولات الهادفه الى خلق
شرعيه من لا
شرعيه تقع على الامم المتحده
مسؤوليه صون مصداقيه
قراراتها مع واجب الادراك الجماعي بان دعم
التنفيذ الكامل
لقراراتها هو حفظ
لهبه هته
المنظمه وفي هذا
الاطار اجدد دعمنا لجهود الامين العام
لمنظمه الامم
المتحده السيد انطونيو وتريش ومبعوثه
الشخصي في مساعي اعاده بحث مسار المفاوضات
المباشره من اجل تنظيم استفتاء يسمح
بتقرير مصير الشعب الصحراوي طبقا لقرارات
مجلس
الامن سيد
الرئيس ان بلادي وهي تتابع باهتمام
بالغ الاضطرابات المقلقه في بعض الدول
الشقيقه
والصديقه تواصل بدل قصار جهدها للعمل على
ايجاد حلول
سلميه وجمع الفرقاء
من اجل تقريب المواقف ووجهات
النظر ففيما يتعلق بالوضع في ليبيا
الشقيقه اؤكد هنا دعمنا لجهود الامم
المتحده الراميه لايجاد حل
سياسي يقوده الليبيون انفسهم ويمكنهم من
الحفاظ على وحده ليبيا وسياده وسلامه اراض
اما بخصوص الوضع في
مالي اني اجدد عزم الجزائر التي تتولى
رياضه الوساطه الدوليه ورئاسه لجنه متابعه
تن فيذ اتفاق السلم
والمصالحه المنبثق عن مصار الجزائر على
مواصله
جهودها للتجاوز لتجاوز
صعوبات التي يعيشها هذا البلد الشقيق مع
التاكيد
مجددا على موقفنا
الرافض للجوء الى القوه لفض
النزاعات بالنسبه لوضع المستجد في الجار
النيجر فالجزائر
تؤكد تمسكها بالعوده الى النظام
الدستوري بالطرق السلميه وتغلي الحلول
السياسيه
والدبلوماسيه واحترام متطلبات دوله
القانون وتدعو الى توخي
الحذر امام نوايا التدخل العسكري
الاجنبي لما له من عواقب خطيره على امن
واستقرار النيجر والمنطقه
كلها وفي نفس الوقت فان الوضع الباعث على
القلق في السودان يستوقفنا لدعوه كافه
الاطراف الشقيقه الى وقف النزاع وتغليب
لغه الحوار
لانها حاله الاقتتال
لانهاء حاله الاقتتال وما لها من تداعيات
على الوضع
الانساني وبالتاكيد
فان هته الاوضاع
الهشه وغير المستقره
تلقي بضلالها على
منظمه على منطقه الساحل والصحراء التي
تعاني من ضعف ومعدلات
التنميه وما يشبه
المجاعه
وانعكاسات التغييرات
المناخيه الامر الذي يزيد من حده عدم
الاستقرار ويغدي الجماعات
الارهابيه التي تتخذ من المنطقه ملادا
لنشاطها
الاجرامي وفي هذا
السياق لا تتون الجزائر في دعم الجهود
التنمويه لدول المنطقه
ومشاركه
تجربتها في مكافحه الارهاب والتطرف العنيف
حيث قدمت الى القمه
الاستثنائيه ل
الاتحاد الافريقي المنعقد في ملبو يوم 28
ماي
باعتبار
باعتبارنا منسقا لمكافحه الارهاب والتطرف
العنيف في
افريقيا وتقريرا عن تطور التهديد الارهاب
في افريقيا واليات
مكافحته وهو التقرير الذي يعرض جمله من
الاليات العمليه لتعزيز مكافحه الارهاب في
افريقيا ويشدد على ضروره وضع قضيه مكافحه
الارهاب على راس
اولويات العمل الافريقي
المشترك وعلى صعيد
اخر
ولان اسهامات الجزائر في جهود الوساطه
الدوليه لا تنحصر في في نطاقها
الجغرافي انخرطت بلادي بصدق في جهود
مجموعه الاتصال
العربيه التي تهدف الى المساهمه في بعث
مفاوضات مباشره بين روسيا
واوكرانيا سيد
الرئيس بعد مضي اكثر من ثمان سنوات على
اعتماد
برنامج 30 للتنميه
المستدامه وخطه عمل ادي
صبيبه لا تزال العديد من الدول الناميه
تواجه
تحديات تستوجب
تضامنا اكثر على المستوى الدولي من اجل
عالم
افضل ونموذج اقتصادي فعال وعادل يسمح
بتحقيق اهداف
التنميه المستدامه
ولقد تبنت الجزائر خطه التنميه المستدامه
ودرجتها
كاولو وطنيه ضمن كل الاستراتيجيات
والبرامج المخططه
الحكوميه حيث مكن ذلك من قطع
اشواط مهمه جدا وتحقيق نتائج معتبره في
مسار اهداف التنميه المستدامه لا سما في
قطاعات
التربيه الصحه البناء الكهرباء والمياه
وعلى ذكر المياه فان بلادي انطلقت ببرنامج
تحليه مياه البحر وسنصل مع نهايه سنه
2024 الى انتاج مليار و300 مليون متر مكعب
يوميا ان شاء
الله سيدي الرئيس ان بلادي التي حضيت بدعم
وثيقه الدول الاعضاء في مجلس حقوق الانسان
لنيل العضويه فيها هي
طرف في معظم المعاهدات الدوليه لحقوق
الانسان وتعمل بكل حرص على تعزيز تعاونها
معه
ومواصله
تنسيقها مع مختلف هيئات
المعاهدات
المعنيه بحقوق الانسان
واليه الاستعراض الدولي
الشامل حيث قدمت بلادي في نوفمبر
2022 تقريرها الوطني الرابع في اطار هته
الاليه وبلادي تامن تؤمن ايمانا عميقا بان
احترام حقوق الانسان
وترقيتها هو حجر الزاويه لاي نظام سياسي
دي مصداقيه وتعمل على تعزيزها بكل الوسائل
الممكنه وهو ايمان
نابع من تمسك الشعب الجزائري بحقوق
الانسان
ويعد التعديل الدستوري في بلادي سنه
اشهاد على قناعاتنا بضروره تعزيز الحقوق
والحريات حيث نص صراحه على انه لا يمكن
ابدا المساس
بجوهرها مكرسا في احكامه المساواه بين كل
المواطنين
والمواطنات في الحقوق
والواجبات بازاله العقبات التي تحول دون
المشاركه الفعاله للجميع لا سما في مجال
ترقيه حقوق المراه وتمكينها سياسيا
واقتصاديا من اجل
ادماجها في مناصب المسؤوليه وتحقيق مبدا
المناصفه في سوق
التشغيل وتعزيز دورها في السلم والامن
وترقيه
مكانتها في مختلف مجالات الحياه على
المستوى الوطني والقاري والدولي
وقد تم اعداد مخطط وطني عملي في اطار
تنفيذ القرار
1325 الصادر من مجلس الامن في اكتوبر
2000 تلتزم من خلاله الجزائر بالحرص على
ترقيه دور المراه في حل
النزاعات والوقايه منها بما يتماشى ومبادئ
السياسه الخارجيه لبلادنا
كما اعتمدت
الجزائر التي تسخر بطاقات
شبانيه
هائله تتجاوز 70% من سكانها
مناهج تمكن من توفير الاطار المؤسسات
والوسائل
الماديه الكفيله بتنميه
قدراتها وادماج
الشباب كقوه
محركه في مسارات
التنميه المستدامه وعلى كافه الاصعده
السياسيه والاقتصاديه
والثقافيه وفي
الختام سنبقى نتطلع الى عالم يسوده الامن
والازدهار
والرفاه
الانساني تحت مضله منظمه الامم المتحده
فلتكون الاراده صادقه والعزائم
قويه لتحقيق تطلعات
شعوبنا المشروعه شكرا على كرم الاصغاء
والسلام
[تصفيق]
عليكم اذا تابعنا واياكم كلمه الرئيس
الجزائري عبد المجيد تبون وقبلها سبقتها
كلمه الرئيس الايراني ابراهيم رئيسي هذا
وقد انطلقت في مقر الامم المتحده بنيويورك
اذا اعمال الدوره 78 للجمعيه العامه تحت
شعار اعاده بناء الثقه وجسور التضامن
العالمي وفي كلمته امام الجمعيه العامه
للامم المتحده قال الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن ان ايران يجب ان لا تمتلك ابدا
اسلحه نوويه متهما اياها بزعزع الامن
الاقليمي والعالمي واضاف بايدن ان روسيا
تتحمل مسؤوليه الحرب في اوكرانيا وهي
قادره على
انهائها
روسيا وحدها تتحمل مسؤوليه هذه الحرب
وروسيا وحدها قادره على انهاء هذه الحرب
فورا روسيا وحدها هي التي تقف في طريق
السلام لان الكلفه الروسيه للسلام هي
انصياع اوكرانيا والاستيلاء على اراضيها
واطفالها روسيا تعتقد ان العالم سيتعب
وسيسمح لها بمعامله اوكرانيا بوحشيه دون
عواقب علينا ان نقف في وجه العدوان الروسي
السافر اليوم لردع اي معتدين محتملين
اخرين في
الغد دوري قال رئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان ان بلاده تسعى جاهده منذ بدايه
الحرب في اوكرانيا لابقاء الطرفين الروسي
والاوكراني حول طاوله المفاوضات واضاف
اردوغان في كلمه امام الجمعيه العامه ان
تركيا ستكثف جهودها لانهاء الحرب من خلال
دبلوماسيه والحوار على اساس استقلال
اوكرانيا ووحده اراضيها
منذ بدايه الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه سعينا
جاهدين لابقاء اصدقائنا الاوكرانيين
والروش حول الطاوله مع فرضيه ان الحرب لن
يكون فيها فائزون ولن يكون في السلام اي
خاسرين وسوف نكثف جهودنا لانهاء الحرب من
خلال الدبلوماسيه والحوار على اساس
استقلال اوكرانيا وسلامه اراضيها ومن خلال
مبادره البحر الاسود التي ل قناها
بالتعاون مع الامم المتحده منعنا خطر حدوث
ازمه جوع عالميه من خلال ضمان ايصال
33 مليون طن من الحبوب عبر البحر الاسود
الى الاسواق العالميه الا ان عدم تنفيذ
هذا الاتفاق بكافه عناصره جعل العالم
يواجه ازمه جديده وقد تم تمديد هذه
المبادره ثلاث مرات جزئيا بفضل جهودنا
لدينا خطه جديده يتم موجبها ايصال مليون
طن اخرى من الحبوب الى البلدان التي هي في
امس الحاجه اليها في جميع انحاء
العالم وفي كلمته امام الجمعيه العامه
للامم المتحده قال العاهل الاردني الملك
عبد الله الثاني ان عام
20123 كان الاكثر دمويه بالنسبه للشعب
الفلسطيني خلال ال 15 عاما الماضيه وجدد
العاهل الاردني دعوته الى اقامه دوله
فلسطينيه مستقله عاصمتها ال قدس
الشرقيه يمكننا ان نرى الشعب الاسرائيلي
يدافع ويعبر عن هويته الوطنيه ومع ذلك فان
الشعب الفلسطيني محروم من نفس الحق الشرط
الاساسي لذلك هو اقامه دوله فلسطينيه
مستقله قابله للحياه على خطوط الرابع من
يونيو عام
1967 وعاصمتها القدس الشرقيه والعيش الى
جانب اسرائيل في سلام وامن وازدهار تاخير
العداله والسلام جلب دورات لا نهايه لها
من
العنف قال امير دوله قطر الشيخ تميم بن
حمد ال ثاني في كلمته امام الجمعيه العامه
للامم المتحده انه لا يجوز ان يبقى الشعب
الفلسطيني اسير تعسف الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
الاستيطاني واضاف امير دوله قطر ان
اسرائيل ترد على مبادرات السلام والتطبيع
العربي بمزيد من التعنت والاستيطان وتهويد
القدس وتشديد الخناق على قطاع
غزه فلا يجوز ان يبقى الشعب الفلسطيني
اسير تعسف الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
الاستيطاني ورفض الحكومات الاسرائيليه
المتعاقبه اي حل سياسي عادل وفق مبادئ
الشرعيه الدوليه ولا يغيب عنكم ان تقاعس
المنظمات الدوليه عن اتخاذ اجراءات ضد
الاحتلال اتاح ويتيح الفرصه لاسرائيل لكي
تقوض اسس حل الدولتين بالتوسع
والاستيطان حتى اصبح الاحتلال يتخذ شكلا
نظام فصل عنصري في وضح نهار القرن ال
21 وقال امير دوله قطر الشيخ تمم بن حمد
ال ثاني في كلمته امام الجمعيه العامه
للامم المتحده ان طريق حل النزاعات بالطرق
السلميه طويل وشاق لكنه اقل كلفه من
الحروب ان طريق حل النزاعات بالطرق
السلميه هو هو طريق طويل طويل وشاق لكنه
اقل كلفه من الحروب والتزامنا بمواصله
جهودنا في تيسير وصناعه السلام هو التزام
مبدئي وهو في صلب سياساتنا
الخارجيه وقال امير دوله قطر الشيخ تمم بن
حمد ال ثاني ان بلاده تدين الجرائم
المرتكبه ضد المدنيين في الخرطوم ودارفور
وتدعو لمحاسبه مرتكبيها وفيما يتعلق
بالوضع في ليبيا اعرب امير دوله قطر عن
دعم بلاده الدائم لمساعي الممثل الخاص
للامين العام للامم المتحده وجهوده لحل
الازمه في ليبيا اما بخصوص لبنان فقال
الشيخ تميم بن حمد ال ثاني ان دوله قطر
تؤكد ضروره ايجاد حل للفراغ الرئاسي بعد
ان بات الخطر محدقا بمؤسسات الدوله في
لبنان
نحن ندين الجرائم المرتكبه ضد المدنيين في
العاصمه الخرطوم وفي اقليم
دارفور وندعو لمحاسبه مرتكبيها كما ندعو
الى وقف القتال والاحتكام لصوت العقل
وتجنيب المدنيين تبعات القتال وفي لبنان
الشقيق حيث اصبح الخطر محدقا بمؤسسات
الدوله نؤكد على ضروره ايجاد حل مستداما
للفراغ السياسي وايجاد الاليات لعدم
تكراره وتشكيل حكومه قادره على تلبيه
تطلعات الشعب اللبناني والنهوض به من
ازماته الاقتصاديه والتنمويه وفي الشان
الليبي نؤكد دعمنا الدائم لمساعي المثل
الممثل الخاص للامين العام ورئيس بعثه
الامم المتحده للدعم في ليبيا وجهوده
المبذوله لتحقيق نتائج ملموسه لحل الازمه
الليبيه وقال امير دوله قطر الشيخ تميم بن
حمد ال ثاني في كلمته امام الجمعيه العامه
للامم المتحده ان بلاده تجدد الدعوه
لتوحيد الجهود لمنع اساءه استخدام الفضاء
السبراني نجدد الدعوه لتوحيد الجهود لمنع
اساءه استخدام الفضاء السبراني وتنظيم هذا
الجانب الحيوي استنادا لاحكام القانون
الدولي وفي هذا السياق ستنعقد في الدوحه
قمه الويب 20 24 ويشكل انعقادها فرصه هامه
لاستعراض التطور في مجال التكنولوجيا وخلق
فرص تعاون جديده في عالم التكنولوجيا
لصالح البشريه
[موسيقى]
جمعان الى ليبيا حيث تكافح رق الانقاذ
للعثور على جثث ضحايا السيول التي اجتاحت
مدينه درنا في ظل تحذيرات متزايده من
الاضرار البيئيه والصحيه لتحلل هذه الجثث
والتفشي المحتمل للامراض نتيجه ذلك في
الاثناء اعلنت السلطات المحليه تقسيم
المدينه وفقا لحجم الضرر الذي اصابها
واقامت حواجز ومناطق عازله بينها تحسبا
لتفشي امراض كانت الامم المتحده قد حذرت
اخيرا من امكانيه تسببها فيما سمته ازمه
مدم
ثانيه وقالت مصادر عسكريه ليبيه انه تم
نقل عشرات العسكريين والمسعفين العاملين
في مدينه درنا الى المستشفى بعد اصابتهم
باعراض اعياء واغماء واسهال وقي ولم تكشف
تلك المصادر عن خلفيات الحادثه هذا وتجرى
تحريات وفحوصات معمقه للمصابين للكشف عن
الاسباب الحقيقيه لتلك
الاعراض
معنا من درنا مراسل الجزيره محمد البقالي
محمد ما اخر التحديثات من خلال المجهودات
التي تتابعها اخر التحات من خلال
المجهودات التي
تتابعها سلمى الواضح ان هناك رغبه من قبل
السلطات المحليه ارسال رساله طمانه للسكان
وللمقيمين ذلك ان خبر دخول عدد من
العسكريين والمنقذين والمسعفين الى
المستشفى بسبب اعراض من تلك التي ذكرت
الاسهال القيء وغير ذلك في ظل هذه الظروف
يصبح الامر مثيرا للقلق ولل المخاوف لان
هذه الاعراض تشير الى امراض بعينها تنتشر
في مثل هذه الكوارث وهي على كل حال
ليست امراض بسيطه لذلك كان هذا الخبر قد
اثار كثير من القلق والفزع في في اوساط
الناس وايضا في اوساط الموجودين وايضا حتى
في صفوف الذين يشتغلون في عمل الانقاذ لكن
وزير الصحه هذا اليوم او ربما قبل ساعتين
من الان تحدث وقال بان الامر لا علاقه له
بالوباء ولا علاقه له بمرض معدي وانما
يتعلق بامراض سماها تحدث بالتماس وهي
امراض بالنسبه
لتوصيف تحدث في مثل
حالات الانقاذ او في حالات اخراج الجثث
بمعنى انه اعتبر ان الامر تحت السيطره ولا
يشكل خطوره ولا يتوقع ان يتحول الى وباء
على كل حال هذا الامر بطبيعه الحال يثير
ويعيد الى الواجهه النقاش بشان الوضع
الصحي وهذا الجدل الذي اصبح بين منذر
ومحذر وبين مطمئن ومؤكد بان الامور تحت
السيطره بالنسبه لوزاره الصحه في الحكومه
المكلفه من قبل البرلمان تؤكد بانه لا
داعي ل خوف وانه ليس هناك اي مؤشر على
حدوث اي كارثه صحيه وهذا الامر التقت فيه
مع ما قاله ممثل منظمه الصحه العالميه
الذي اكد بان الجثث التي دفنت او التي
توجد تحت الانقاض لا يتوقع ان تشكل اي خطر
وان تتسبب في اي وباء ما دامت هذه الجثث
شكرا توفي اصحابها باسباب اخرى غير
الامراض الخطيره ولكن هذا لا يمنع من
تحذيرات تصدر من وزاره الصحه نفسها تدعو
الناس الى الانتباه الى او تحذر الناس من
شرب مياه الابار الجوفيه مع دعوات الى
القيام
بضروره مراقبه هذه المياه لا تشكل تكون
سببا في انتشار الامراض محمد البقالي
مراسلنا من درنا شكرا
[موسيقى]
لك
تداعيات زلزال الحوس في المغرب حيث تتواصل
عمليات البحث والاغاثه لليوم الثاني عشر
على التوالي في غضون ذلك اعلنت السلطات
المغربيه مواصله عمليه فتح الطرق الجبليه
المؤديه الى القرى النائيه المتضرره من
الزلزال وقد بدات السلطات احصاء المباني
المتضرره تمهيدا لاعاده الاعمار ونقل
مراسل الجزيره عن مسؤولين محليين في اقليم
الحوز ان عمليه احصاء المنازل الايله
للسقوط جراء الزلزال ستستمر نحو 12
يوما معنا من مراكش مراسل الجزيره عمر
الحاج عمر حدثنا عن المجهودات الحكوميه
وايضا الشعبيه والمدنيه لاحتواء تداعيات
الزلزال الى اين
وصلت نعم سلمى المجهودات الان منصبه بشكل
كبير على
عمليات مساعده من تم من نجى من الزلزال
والان هو في الخيم المؤقته بمدهم بكل
اسباب الحياه سواء من ايصال المياه
اعطائهم خطوط الكهرباء او حتى تزويدهم بها
اضافه الى جهود اقل درجه على البحث عننا
جنا محتملين او جهود اخراج الجثث من تحت
الانقاض هذه العمليات عمليات الانقاض
تضائلت بشكل كبير خلال 24 ساعه المنصرمه
حتى ان فرق الانقاذ الاجنبيه يبدو انها
غادرت البلاد وذلك استنادا الى ما رايناه
من انفضاض المخيم الذي كان مخصصا لتنسيق
عمليات هذه الفرق جنبا الى جنب مع عمليات
الفرق الوطنيه ايضا ما يتزال هناك خطوره
سلمى حقيقيه وذلك نتيجه انهيارات الصخريه
التي لا تتوقف خاصه في اقليم الحوز وذلك
كلما اقتربنا من مركز الز سواء في ايجل او
حتى تت بن يعقوب التي كنا بها التي كنا
فيها اليوم ايضا الجهود مصبه ايضا على
العمليه التعليميه التي تمت يوم امس التي
استؤنفت يوم امس هناك مجهودات في بناء
مدارس مؤقته في المناطق المتضرره وهناك
جهود لنقل الطلاب الى مراكش الطلبه في
البلدات التي يصعب انشاء مدارس مؤقته فيها
وذلك نتيجه للخطوره ونتيجه ايضا لانقطاع
الطرق المحتمل نحن نتحدث عن اكثر من 6000
طالب تم نقلهم الى مراكش وتامينه سواء في
منشات اعدتها الدوله وحتى في دور للايتام
حتى يتلقوا التعليم وذلك بشكل بشكل المبيت
كما اعتاد البعض منهم على ذلك في مدن
والبلدات اخيرا فقط اتحدث عن جهود مد
المواطنين الذين اضطرت منازلهم بالمنح
الماديه والتي بدات بصرف مكافاه او منحه
ماليه بقيمه 250 دولار شهريا لمده 12 شهرا
شكرا لك عمر الحاج مراسلنا من
مراكش اعلنت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه ان
ثلاثه شبان فلسطيني فلسطينيين استشهدوا
واصيب نحو 30 اخرين خلال اقتحام قوات
الاحتلال مدينه جنين ومخيمها وافاد شهود
عيان بان ان جنود الاحتلال حاصروا منزلا
يعود لعائله قائد كتائب شهداء الاقصى
الذراع العسكريه لحركه فتح احمد ابو
البهاء هذا واخلى جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
سبيل المواطنين الفلسطينيين الاثنين او
الفلسطينيين الاثنين الذين اعتقله ما خلال
عمليه عسكريه في
جنيب وقالت كتائب القسام ان مجاهديها
استهدفوا جرافه لجيش الاحتلال المقتحم
لمخيم جنين بعبوه ناسفه موقع موقعين
اصابات مؤكده من جهتها قالت كتيبه جنين
التابعه لسرايا القدس انها اصابت اليات
الاحتلال بشكل مباشر بسلسله من العبوات
المتفجره بعد رصدها قوه خاصه اسرائيليه
حاولت التسلل داخل مخيم جنين وفي اطار
ردود الفعل قالت الرئاسه الفلسطينيه انها
تدين جرائم الاحتلال بحق الشعب الفلسطيني
في جنين وغزه ومختلف المدن الفلسطينيه
اما حركه حماس فقالت ان كل جرائم الاحتلال
بحق الشعب الفلسطيني ومقدساته لن تمر دون
عقاب ولن تكسر ارادته
وصلابته اعلنت وزاره الصحه في قطاع غزه
استشهاد شاب فلسطيني واصابه 11د اخرين
برصاص قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي خلال
مسيرات في المناطق الحدوديه شرقيه القطاع
وقد شارك عشرات شبان الفلسطينيين في
مظاهرات شعبيه نصره للمسجد الاقصى وتنديدا
بالاقتحام والانتهاكات الاسرائيليه واشعل
المتظاهرون الاطارات المطاطيه ورفعوا
اعلام فلسطين قرب السياج الامني قبل ان
تطلق عليهم قوات الاحتلال الرصاص الحي
وقنابل الغاز المسيل للدموع
ختام الحصاد الى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء
n